ah
[Música]
ok pues bueno muchísimas gracias y
buenas tardes mi nombre es jorge ortiz y
primero que nada quiero agradecerles
porque está en un top en una charla ted
pues yo creo que es una experiencia no
solamente para para quienes lo organizan
sino para ustedes como audiencia y para
nosotros que tratamos de compartir un
poco sobre lo que hacemos y bueno el
título de la plática si es la juventud
en el méxico y su impacto yo quisiera
preguntarles nada más rápidamente
quién de ustedes al día de hoy
a sentido que como joven
no ha dado a lo mejor el 100% en su
trayectoria y que cree que todavía está
pues en las últimas de poder hacer algo
que levante la mano
muy bien la mayoría y primero que nada
cuando a mí me hacen la pregunta oye
jorge para ti que es la juventud
yo les dio les decía es que yo no puedo
encasillarla en que es un periodo de
tiempo o que es un estado emocional o
qué es lo que dice la ley la ley dice
que es de 10 de 12 a 29 años yo veo que
la juventud para iniciar esta plática es
definir qué es que ser joven que son los
ajustes en las juventudes en guanajuato
y en méxico y cómo estamos impactando de
alguna forma en el país en la sociedad
en esa universidad y qué más podemos
hacer para crear un cambio un impacto
cuando yo tenía 12 años y me hacen mi
encuesta oye jorge lo que quieres como
joven que pides como joven a los 12 años
de 2 a 15 años y cada que iban a mi
secundaria yo les decía y me acuerdo que
mis compañeros también lo hacíamos
queremos canchas queremos áreas de
diversión
queremos dispersar nos queremos deporte
queremos becas entonces bueno en su
momento se nos daba a nosotros como
jóvenes esas peticiones después de 15 a
18 años cuando ya estaba yo en la prepa
llegó la misma encuesta
tú que vives como joven cuáles son tus
necesidades y pues ahí ya cambiaron ya
no pedía más deporte yo pedía mi beca
para poder estudiar en una buena
preparatoria tener alguna algún tipo de
beca ya sea alimenticia económica pero
ya mencionada en pedir algo que fuera
que aportar a mí a mi futuro entre
comillas después a los 18 años de 1822
llegó la misma encuesta
yo me empezaba a preguntar por qué no se
hacen encuestas casi cada dos o tres
años
y en la universidad ya les decía bueno
yo quisiera de entrada
que cuando vaya a pedir un trabajo no me
pregunten mi experiencia porque si voy
saliendo de la universidad aunque haya
hecho algún tipo de labor no los puestos
o las empresas que están al frente de la
economía mexicana le van a pedir
experiencia de uno o dos o tres años y
realmente no la tengo como lo hago yo lo
que pido es flexibilidad que sean
flexibles conmigo para yo poder entonces
tener seguridad y poder empezar a
aprender porque las ganas de aprender
siempre están y ser buen estado y
después de la universidad llegó otra
encuesta pero ya lluvia no llegó a la
universidad ya llegó a de manera
personal por correo y me decían tú como
joven que tienes veintitantos 23 24
hacia 29 tú que pedirías o qué es lo que
crees que hace falta y completamente mi
visión cambió
aquí les traigo unos datos duros sobre
la población en méxico
escuché violencia de algunos dos años
tres años de un director de juventud a
nivel nacional y él decía que el 2020
tendríamos ese sería el año o es el año
ya porque ya estamos en este año que
habría más jóvenes en la historia de
méxico y que el 2021 iban a empezar a
bajar los los jóvenes entonces eso fue
en 2017 ya pasado entonces años y aquí
lo que les muestro es que efectivamente
el 30 por ciento bueno esto está un poco
desactualizado el 31 por ciento de la
población en méxico según el inegi son
los jóvenes entonces es más es un tercio
de la población
aquí en guanajuato tenemos
5 millones de habitantes
de los cuales
más del millón vela y los daños entre
hombres y mujeres más del millón y poco
más son mujeres un millón 25 mil son
hombres
y otro dato nuevo nada más para concluir
si con la historia
en el uso de las drogas que aparte es un
tema que gana 4
hay un porcentaje mucho más alto en
mujeres y es algo que me personal a mí
me genera una preocupación pero no es
una preocupación de qué
solamente para platicar lo compartido en
redes sino que poder hacer algo al
respecto
entonces continuando con la historia
cuando me preguntan a mí a los 25 20 y
26 años
oye jorge lo que puedes pedir como joven
y lo dispuesto en el correo fue más que
pedir algo más que solicitar algo lo que
yo quisiera es una que me dé la
oportunidad de poder hacer un cambio
junto con ustedes porque ustedes como
gobierno o con empresas privadas creen
que la juventud y a veces pasa si a
veces no que la juventud se se maquila o
se hace una estrategia detrás de un
escritorio y la verdad es que no la
juventud ciones todos nosotros con ideas
con proyectos como podemos nosotros
tangibilizar los y eso es un reto que
tenemos yo creo que la mayor hará aquí y
no solamente aquí sino desde los 12 años
cómo podemos hacer que nos hagan caso a
nosotros que quedan en mi proyecto o
iniciativa en mi campaña cómo le hago
para fusionar ambos mundos
los jóvenes tan irreverentes
rápido en su pensamiento con el mundo
tan lento de los corporativos de las
empresas que va paso a paso como
logramos esta fusión entre ambas partes
es lo que yo coloque en mi correo el que
me permite a mí apoyar con algo que
puede hacer al respecto yo creo que hay
muchas cosas y no solamente yo sino
todos nosotros y es parte de lo que
también les voy a compartir antes de
pasar este vídeo quiero que empiece una
a pensar ustedes como jóvenes mexicanos
y lo que les pregunta al principio es lo
que consideran que aún les hace falta
hacer para que de alguna manera con este
vídeo que van a ver empiezan a idear
cómo iniciar porque también el retroceso
no solamente entender el proyecto sino
cómo empiezo con quién me acerco
tenemos instancias de juventud que son
magníficas
tenemos la academia tenemos amistades y
benditas radios sociales que nos apoyan
a compartir lo que sentimos
realmente cómo empiezo lo puesto en mi
facebook algún proyecto soy joven quien
se une quien jala
voy con la universidad
junto a mis amigos tengo las puertas con
quien algún parque tecnológico voy con
el banco es decir hay muchos caminos
para que lo importante es que ustedes
empiecen una a detectar qué es lo que
quieren hacer que contribuya pues a su
municipio a la ciudad y que a la vez
vaya de la mano con su chamba porque de
algo hay que vivir o de su proyecto
méxico necesita mucho más de nosotros
como jóvenes entonces es momento de
empezar y de idear y yo sé que en este
ya ustedes están haciendo cosas tengo ex
alumnos por aquí y sé que son unos están
son unos cracks están haciendo cosas muy
buenas a edades muy cortas si nos vamos
a otra escuela por decir un nombre donde
estuve también trabajando en el colegio
oviedo junto al parque metropolitano es
increíble como desde los 12 años que
están en secundaria ya están creando
robots programando aplicaciones están
concursando en japon y ganando cuando en
mis épocas estábamos en mecanografía
apenas tecleando o jugando solitario en
las computadoras de la de la escuela
entonces los tiempos de verdad que
cambiaron y van a seguir cambiando y
pues ocupamos gente con ustedes que
tengan una iniciativa y bueno les voy a
compartir 10 puntos que en lo personal
considero que son importantes y que me
han servido para poder quitarme el miedo
la pereza dejar de procrastinar y me han
apoyado si algo les pueden servir les
área de lujo
una vez que sean ustedes aunque me pasa
a mí es que trataba siempre de
compararme con alguien con mi mejor
amigo con él influencer con el
empresario
y la verdad de las cosas que nunca iba a
ser como ellos yo soy yo jorge ortiz no
soy nadie más no busco que me comparen
con algún referente sin referentes me
contactan para mí va a ser un gusto y un
honor pero siempre se trata de ser tú
mismo
busca una inspiración hoy en día es tan
fácil que te puedas inspirar tenemos las
historias que avanzan tan rápido el
instagram
en todas las redes sociales compartimos
con personas todo el tiempo los que
están estudiando con sus profesores con
conferencistas
encuentran una motivación y una
inspiración que te impulse a poder
conseguir algo que te puedes hacer amigo
de esa persona pues mucho mejor
tener una perspectiva como en la
temática de aquí de dt en la que se
encuentra tu perspectiva y tras una ruta
si tú crees que tu trayectoria ha sido
muy enfocada al marketing en crear
contenido web se vende lo puedes
monetizar no tengas miedo de hacerlo
sigue adelante esto se dice y se escucha
tan fácil que en realidad no lo es que
es seguir adelante tener problemas
económicos y aún así seguir cortar con
tu novia con tu novio y aún así seguir
adelante que tu familia tu mamá tu papá
estén enfermos que tengas que seguir
estudiando y pensar o trabajo o estudio
llevó dinero a la casa que agua pues eso
accionar seguir adelante y que tu puedas
yo sé que el tema de la depresión no es
nada sencillo y qué
y los que algún momento han sentido que
no pertenecen
lo puedan entender el seguir adelante es
a pesar de tus circunstancias que no te
caigas y que no te rindas sino que sigas
tratando de tú misma sobresalir
a ahorrar ahora los logros yo les
pregunto de dónde se aprende más de un
éxito levante la mano no se quiera que
de un éxito se aprende más que de un
fracaso
ok y levantan la mano los que crean que
el fracaso es el principal maestro
ok bueno en mi experiencia efectivamente
porque el fracaso al final del día te va
a dar una lección completamente distinta
y te va a poner los pies sobre la tierra
te va a enseñar a que lo que tú pensabas
que estaba bien y realmente no lo es y
es muy diferente a lo como tú lo tienes
pensado que si querías conseguir un
cliente los que son emprendedores y
llegas y te dice tu cliente sabes que yo
cupo que mínimo que puedas firmar un
contrato que me vas a abastecer dos años
pero tu emprendimiento es tan chiquito
que no tienes la capacidad operativa de
hacerlo entonces es empezar a ahorrar
los fracasos para que te ayuden en un
futuro a sacar toda la energía para
ahora sí ponerte las pilas y seguir
adelante que fue el punto 4
a las cosas a tu manera es decir no
creas conflicto en el estilo propio pero
sigue haciendo las cosas como tú crees
que se hacen es importante algo para que
no se malentienda puedes tener consejos
y depende quién te los de cuándo las
absorba el es el estilo que vas a
manejar porque de repente encontrado
también algunas personas jóvenes y en
jóvenes y es triste que de repente digan
yo así soy así nací así no voy a morir
no voy a cambiar cuando tienen 18 años o
19 o 20 y dices oye pero tu flexibilidad
mental te da para cambiar puedes
aprender y aprender nuevas cosas porque
te enfocas en que naciste aceite vas a
morir o sea no tienes todavía mucho que
aprender entonces aquí la cosa es que
ustedes hagan las cosas a su manera pero
siempre haciendo flexibles en que pueden
cambiar el destino de ustedes y de
alguna cualquier persona
[Música]
esto es muy importante porque hay una
frase que dice deja que tu trabajo haga
todo el ruido
sabemos como jóvenes queremos siempre
salud rockstar aparece en todos lados
pero qué pasa cuando esa necesidad de
atención o de reconocimiento no llega
llega la frustración ya no me gustó lo
que hice la de nuevo a ver yo soy tan
bueno me faltan likes me faltan vistas
entonces aquí lo que aparta trato de
decirles es dejen que su trabajo que su
chamba haga todo el éxito y todo el
ruido alguien se va a enterar alguien
les va a reconocer cuando menos se den
cuenta porque siempre pasa es una ley
natural si ustedes estaban esforzándose
mucho créanme que va a ser imposible que
nadie se dé cuenta alguien se va dar
cuenta y te va a decir sabes que nos
dimos cuenta que estás haciendo un
evento que quieres emprender te ayudamos
porque se empiezas a platicar de más
también se vuelve un problema
encuentro un balance el balance es como
la vida perdón es como la bicicleta si
dejas de pedalear
pero para acá para acá de las dos te
caes
el poder a otros la palabra de ese 2020
es empoderamiento a hombres a mujeres a
niños a todo el mundo pero como puedes
empoderar a alguien si tú pues no te
empodera a ti mismo y aquí no tiene que
ver con el arles bonito a alguien
simplemente es comparte tu experiencia a
alguien le puede servir y los 'tests'
son para eso por eso estamos hoy aquí
y sé provocativo tiene ya estilo sabes
manejar tu ritmo de trabajo todos los
puntos que vivimos pero vuélvete alguien
ancla que las personas puedan observar y
que puedas tú también ser una referencia
para ellos
bueno aquí le sale un poco también de la
incubadora logró a brincar
aquí son algunas fotografías de una
asociación en la que estuve en la cual
me dejó mucho aprendizaje que es aiesec
y son lo puse aquí porque son recuerdos
que me hacen me hacen saber de dónde
vengo no sé a dónde voy no sé si mañana
tendré algún proyecto más en la bolsa si
me van a invitar a otro evento si voy a
tener otra mascota si familia va a estar
conmigo no sé hacia dónde voy pero como
dice la canción reciente de residente no
sé hacia dónde voy
si sé de dónde vengo
dice que van a billy cosas muy padres
aquí tuve la fortuna de tener unos
colombianos colaborando en méxico y que
pues ellos están creando sus propios
negocios en su país
he podido colaborar con municipios en
los que nunca imaginé que iba a
colaborar como san felipe como cuerámaro
como silao y otros estados que también
son una experiencia grata para mí poder
mencionarlos
tuve la oportunidad de llenar el clímax
con un evento también
puede crear esas marcas guzmán del
límite suena el yo también una de las
aquí es una es un ejemplo de que las
cosas se pueden lograr de que está
orgulloso de los hijos que tú creaste y
estos son algunos de los que yo he
podido hacer no voy a profundizar en
ellos lovely productor musical
esta es una canción del estudiante de
aquí balance que se la producimos en
2017 y que bueno al día de hoy el chalo
ya fue su punta de lanza para poder
crear más cosas
y bueno les agradezco mucho la y las
gracias
[Música]
ah